can we talk about one of my favorite
things something we can do at any time
of the day
in any of our rooms at home since we're
all at home
that's right i'm talking about online
shopping
and i'm so excited that we've teamed up
with rue la la
an online store where you can get high
quality designer items at amazing prices
and now here with this week's hot rue
lala items is
my friend and co-host kelana barfield
brown
hi drew hi partner oh my gosh
you are going to be so excited to see
what we have this week
well i see some things burning yeah i
don't think
okay so this is actually our first item
it's october we're all home
and we're all trying to elevate our
spaces so
all the items i'm going to talk about
today are just for that starting with
these candles these are the aqua de soy
lusso three candle bundle and you get
all three of these together
they smell incredible so here in this
bundle we have
two very fresh scents ocean palm and
santorini breeze
and then there's a woody scent that's
golden sandal so i like that there's a
mix you can play
play around depending on your mood it is
nice to see a candle
not in just glass i never see that yeah
i thank them for doing it differently
yeah i love these tin
cans and they are you know this set
normally goes for as high as
69 today we're getting it for 32.99
that's a 52 discount and that's the kind
of price
i like right i'm i'm i'm definitely
like high price sensitive so to me
that feels really to get into our next
item uh
yeah okay so the next item is this
gorgeous
e-carpet gallery faux sheepskin rug
it is so beautiful so soft it's made
from
recycled materials handmade it's a rug
but it almost looks like a throw for
your couch i mean it's
gorgeous we have it in five different
colors but we have three here
so you have the gray i have the brown
and there's the ivory as well and
there's two others on this side oh don't
just don't fight it you know you want it
so these normally go for as high as 179
today we're getting them for 89.99 yes
that is a 49
discount i have to say that again speaks
to
my type of price point yeah i really
love this this really can go all over
the home you can drape it at the end of
your bed yeah
and like pretend you're burt reynolds
and playboy
you can put it at the christmas tree you
can drape it over a dining room chair
or you can just put it on the floor like
a regular carpet and it just will
elevate your space
honey you could get naked on it and just
roll around
and pretend that everything's fine
whatever you
choose to do with your rug is your
business absolutely
okay so our next item i have these
gorgeous gasoline
cookbooks one is dinner with georgia
o'keeffe
and the one next to you is dinner with
jackson pollock so there are 50 great
recipes in each book
and they both have artwork within the
book as well
so you get a mix of both i'm so
passionate
about these two artists and astolene is
one of the best book companies
absolutely
they're they make art in themselves
yeah and then the recipes are really
well done and the storytelling is really
good
absolutely and and the price is great
tell me the price kalani
these cookbooks go for as high as 50
each today we're getting them for 35.99
yeah that's a 28
discount yes this is so worth that price
yeah because really you can interact
with
it so beautifully they're beautiful i i
have both of them i love them so much
i don't have that one yet but for 35
dollars
yes you have to okay so the next is
perfect for you it's perfect for
everyone but
considering you have pets this is the
bob sweet pet hair plus robotic vacuum
cleaner and mop
okay now it's great for pets if you have
pets and pet hair
around your home but it is great just
on its own like i don't have these
really work
so listen i don't have pets but i have a
newborn baby
and this has been cleaning my house for
the last two weeks okay really
the suction on this little thing is
incredible like i was impressed
i was so impressed because i was like is
it really gonna do anything
no it really does it all it so if you
took it and you say you suck
it'd be a compliment it would be a
compliment it
sweeps it mops it vacuums it even
sanitizes with uvc light it
does it all yes and it works on all
different surfaces
on carpet on tile on hardwood floors
it does it all how much is it so it
normally goes for
399.99 today we're getting it for 199.99
so that's a 50 percent just that's
really good
it's really good also like i am not
a bad girl i'm just not that's not going
to do it for me but
pet hair pickup or you know getting down
with my own faux fur over here
or a cookbook rocking the cookbook like
this
feels so conducive to who i am as a
human being yeah
well thank you kalana you're just the
best partner in crime and you can find
these items at ruelala.com
drew and remember these deals are only
available while supplies last
[Music]